back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
I got that meat and [ __ ] dude what
poor man sandwich one of my favorite
things to do is give me a little
lunchable cuz lunchable really make the
perfect size meat yeah they do don't
they it's never enough in there was a
kidney it's just from the fat kid
speaking but it's never enough there's
always four categories I always need
more meat man I thought it was a lot
that's difference between us dude yeah I
looked at a lunch when I was like man
how am I gonna handle it all I looked
down with Mama where's my dunkaroos
without meal pie what are we doing she's
like you're my little oatmeal pie I'm so
hungry
they keep saying that but I'm starving
bro hey that's why we've been good
partners in crime as kids
you gonna give me happy yeah then I've
been full yes true huh I'll tell you
what how about the pants oh he's a eat
the crust off of this real quick hood
I'm that guy
billy-ray thyroid do you look like a
redneck today man yeah dude I heard you
were colorblind so I'm trying to please
your eyes you know with the patterns
yeah heard you're colorblind so I'm like
you know what just give me one of just
kind of mix everything yeah man yeah
dude you definitely dressed like a 40
year old boy that's not sure of his
sexual orientation and bro how many uh
how many uh yes spit it out dude it's
making me laugh on the way dude you like
cuddle up at Barnes & Noble with an warm
but no [ __ ] weird dude
hey man I'm starting a fire dude down
man I just got done with my book club I
got this new trouble pronoun is during
there's okay I'm just saying dude that
hey don't make me [ __ ] cappuccino
you look like somebody well there's
nothing in that can and there hasn't
been for two appetizers
on the row you baby
zoo that's a weak old man you gotta
tighten up tighten up okay hey can I can
read oh that hat seems like a hat that a
six or seven year old girl wears coming
all right
well finally got here you know you
finally got here dude
I understand Lunchables has that perfect
size meat is what I'm trying to tell you
now I'm saying it's never enough for a
kid my size growing up and here's the
other thing those parents during
halftime on my football games always
bring those goddamn orange laughs I need
more I needed more and don't make him so
pull your R's Coco cover of a nice I
can't have these yeah especially and the
funny thing is there's always that kid
who didn't even play and he's eaten half
of this [ __ ] little [ __ ]
yeah couldn't wait for him Randall what
are you doing Randall you down to Capri
Sun gene all the oranges yeah maybe even
play a pro he's too sick to even play in
the second half yeah my mom brought oh
oh yeah and I [ __ ] you bro dude that kid
gets beat when the light when the Sun
Goes Down do you sneak up on the kid
with a broomstick bro little giant style
box now talking all that [ __ ] on your
parents yeah but that's a shirt that I
got for Sadie Hawkins dance whenever I
was in school that was always a Sadie
Hawkins what's been lit play somebody
did burn it down one that's something
yeah is that when the girls ask the boys
that's the winner one right where the
girls ask the dudes when the girls ask
the original me to movement oh yeah yeah
does my first step in the right
direction for Hollywood yeah I mean
we've been doing that forever the girls
ask the boys that's pretty young I don't
know who this little skanks ad is that's
forward thank you
that's forward-thinking right that's all
right nothing made you feel like a
bigger loser when no girl at you the
dance cuz you can't really ask them like
if if it was prom or homecoming you
could ask
40 girls and sound like all right [ __ ]
it dude yeah let's do it cuz it felt bad
but if
no girl asks you and you just roll with
your home yeah as it grew yeah
meet Karl are gonna go just buddy uh
okay we're gonna ride our bikes over
there hey were you the one weren't you
the cyber did in high school drinking
before the dances uh yeah yeah I was not
that guy but you see why you were no I
was not really eating you're like oh
let's meat it out back early who's
somewhat chilly before we get to prom
before like we just say it out Baghdad
like yeah but Chili's is still open
through me open tomorrow man you don't
have to go thing yeah but just hate to
miss them you know you say you get
[ __ ] up for the dance and stuff yeah
we'd have a good time and yeah we're
gonna show up I'm trying to think we
showed up Stone it would usually be
liquor or LSD or some type of exotic
yeah yeah mute like I said your [ __ ] was
lit you boys show up looking like a
lizard
yeah like what the [ __ ] is going on with
yeah who's the kid with the moat and the
fat-ass what's with the bang come back
home like we have I see James the same
DJ that there for everything in town for
the funerals for the weddings for the
dances for the bar mitzvahs all so you
keep asking for bobble service want a
basketball yeah keep screaming wins
juvenile coming out we don't have that
budget know what you think let's mosh if
my going oh you stopped working my goal
was to always dance with the chaperone
teachers that was monkey because in a
weird way it was an opportunity for them
they were still like out with their you
know they were away from home for the
night there was a dance there's love in
the air so it was that one time I feel
like where you could cut in with a
chaperone and be like oh you know it's
Arnold how you have to do it right cuz
they wouldn't be like nah can ya do it
yeah they'd be like why don't you dance
and not to dance with anybody that was
my move I would dance over by them just
by myself slow dance and they'd be like
maybe like oh I got to help this kid out
this is so sad what's up I don't know
what this dance is young dude we had a
guy named it I don't know her name was
mr. psilocybin I think is everybody
called if he was real into drugs and he
got detained one time at UM during
Christmas I was going to midnight mass
and I stopped over at the gas station on
the way there could my friend big Bobby
was over there and he actually kidnapped
somebody one time and went to jail but
this is before that and so I was
thinking what sometimes I start dancing
huh mr. psilocybin they detained him I
just want to say your name but they
detained him big Bobby detained me was
so [ __ ] up at the at the gas station
at the 7-eleven he's like you can't
leave until you sober up so literally
for like two hours that night he was
just hanging out inside he wouldn't let
him out back outside to his car keys too
wasted so I went before church and I
went after church he was still in there
is aka do what's gonna lose our teacher
at school think you want something can I
get you anything he's just hanging out
like three aisles you talking about dude
anyways I'm that good of a story so
let's get him to the episode let's do it
man it wasn't shut up shut up Sadie
Hawkins show super bowl man shout-out to
both of those I told you bro I'm just
sayin I told
who was that boy Ronnie Lott out there
what about most dirt bro monster most
it's good oh I like a little bit of
spicy mustard all right
oh I wondered if you guys had seen this
this is a big video on Instagram I was
curious if you guys
oh man that's why uh that interview dude
is hilarious bro 20/20 you're being run
down the street in my seafood secret in
the backseat of my Honda Accord a girl
get butt-ass that get Rho Rho [ __ ]
Todd I love you are one the rares
personality type on the planet thank you
oh man you got some pretty ass teeth bro
get out of here
dude that's even meeting great I've ever
had that's the same speech that I gave
it my brother's wedding
unbelievable
they came from all gasp no break show
thanks for the video the host will go on
with your back so she's bad dude what
was it all gasp no break it's uh
interviews from the road by Andrew
Callaghan yeah he's great
boys were sober Gang Gang buzz buzz he
threw it out door Todd did get rolled up
I'll say that boy bye everybody bye them
LSU Tigers
he's rolling something up smoking his
own DNA tiny the only thing controlled
on that CPC your good every time we're
gonna sneak it up on the alphabet it
goes wrong my bad I know my drugs I'll
let you take this one PCB man I didn't
know Brendan like to get wet training
deck training days okay but gang gang
buzz-buzz I got through it out in that
viral video really dude man I'm saying
bro get it in there you know hey the
Masters are coming up a lot of people
are gonna be there it'd be a great place
to hear a gang gang Tigers best place to
dit in their gang gang Baba's Nation
escort you away don't worry we'll pay
for your ticket we got you nothing yeah
where else to be a good place to do it
the Masters is good the Masters a
funeral of dope funeral em out doors
doors a tennis one right before they
serve before Serena does yeah first of
all who can't play tennis dude get out
of here with that bull you know I'm
saying put a helmet on and let's see
what happens with these em efforts gang
[ __ ] let's roll brought into something
else little steak right boys oh yeah I'm
segment first up it's Chris D'Elia again
I'm walking out he got another tattoo
incentive as he said he didn't even do
those tattoos he said that Ari Shaffir
hacked his arm this is Papa Bear from
New Jersey Papa Bear has a lot of
honeydew Papa Bear is obviously trying
to hide the fact that he is blatantly
Amish okay it is so Amish can we pull up
Amish man
can we bring up honey booboo can bring
up a honey Boone's Farm
you'll definitely you get Amish man
he definitely has the Amish beard vibe
he doesn't he's true I think it's
trimmed up though
Wow jokes over
yes let's get that guy over there to the
right with the thing on his neck yeah
that's him right there
no with that with the thing on his neck
the red thing gang it looks like me also
there we go that is your boy right there
coming in hot bra then gypsy rude Louie
CK's new Lucas can't wait for his new
hour
yeah his new hour dude it's called the
sunset bro alright let's get back into
it man see this honey boo boo papa
so Brenda Theo what you guys sync my ink
they call me Papa Bear and I have this
Otis to swallow Raven the Bears mouth
just a Papa Bear with some watercolor
very colorful tattoo I'll do sales buddy
Matt my right hand I make with beautiful
art on money green rose the money that
make shaking hands doing business
dollars gonna get this dagger good oh
yeah oh yeah the blood helps with the
business of
you nervous yes your bank teller not
finished
oh oh lighthouse or is that I dick dick
Island that barely leaves thought a
bunch of Skittles ha ha coast but look
if I get lots of wing for cockeyed over
[Laughter]
lighthouse stavroula Jitsu boy papa bear
got that honey
I think like this little too much honey
estate that bears thrown up all the
rainbow skittles into [ __ ] crow I got
some questions your bear throwing up
[ __ ] Jolly Ranchers into a crow yeah
I didn't have a bird I was everybody I
didn't have a bird catch him in your
mouth right above the elbow dude that
cpc's great bro I don't know how much
needlework this guy had but he could
easily have vhi bro you know what some
of this seems like the dark art bro that
bear bear looks like a brother that was
in a fire first of all the honest dude
it looks a little risque lot of colorful
a big more like myself how the guys got
that money tattoo 9 rows for money yeah
you know the green rows of money okay
you don't good for the bill got blood
for what I'm doing this mistake vampire
bad are you kill me just like how you
come to take blood see those body
you gotta make sure you guys well you
get some honey just drip it off your
shoulder bro oh yeah
nobody's gonna believe that honey
dripping on your face big [ __ ] boss
cheats what I'm saying is this big guys
like and if you look right here they got
a mountain range with a barrel full of
cinnamon rollin narrating you can see
there'll be a lighthouse right there
hope you guys don't say anything about
looking like a cop and that dick do I
get roasted baby we got a lot house with
a couple of radish plants around yeah
and there's a femur at the bottom of
femur out of school nah man I think this
is what I'm trying to say is dude I
think this is it looks good bro I think
it's crazy to let somebody draw on you
in a small building dude that's the only
thing I don't understand about tattoo
places you know but respect bro I got
one dude and uh and maybe one day I'll
share but um but yeah I like that I like
this [ __ ] man you got the stars Papa
Bear Dog yeah I like them hairy
shoulders see that [ __ ] stay on Papa
Bear Matt edgy Amish brought you the
edgy Amish gonna get that manscape 3.0
and try shaving your shoulders you let
that [ __ ] grow bro like a Papa Bear keep
the color - they're gonna tell you don't
go color but I like it man yeah I think
if you let some of the hair grow in and
then make that part of the foliage Dada
hair green
so what I would do is I grow on what I
would know this is what I would do I
don't wear the skulls that just let the
hair grow here so it looks like a full
human gothic Wellborn and always seen
[ __ ] I thought lighthouse is a place
your votes to get to okay you thought
shutter island' yeah I thought [ __ ]
Island you thought shudder legs I want
some of that Weiner big dog battleship
showing up huh
that ship sunk baby yeah really that's
you just ripped that guy you're drinking
out of that empty can again to you what
are you talking about bro I don't know
dude you went bad on Papa Bear to me I
did not that's a beautiful I can't be a
man shut up to your neck beard I like
all that beard is ice cold man but
shoutouts ain't money thanks for sending
it in Nick they know we're gonna rip it
up when they send it right yeah yeah
we're gonna sink it okay starving
are you yep well dude don't waste time
running to the store yourself man or
what do you I don't have the energy to
go right now hook yourself you just
start cooking no no you're not doing
that dude no what do you think it's 1905
yeah you right dude
you're right use post fades dude you
need red wine at 4 p.m.
sushi at 9 p.m. how about a breakfast
burrito for your thick lips I do have
one big lip yeah you do dude hey you
want that bubble gum and lip huh I got
that Lester Holt we're all on the low
side look I don't know what you're
talking about posts mates anything
you're craving post mates they can
deliver it is that right that's right
dude 24 hours a day 365 days a year
post mates will bring you what you need
within an hour and what and what do they
do like is it what is it what do you
want dude name of food I know what it is
Oh
it's basically your own personal
assistant picks your food up drops off
work what about a donut sure I'll get
you donut what about an omelet sure dude
what about a couple links a sausage yeah
don't tell anybody
ah as long as you film you eating it uh
24 hours a day 365 days a year all right
download the app for iOS or Android for
free and browse local restaurants is
that right Brendan yeah browse and bro
Brown businesses you can track your
delivery in real time in case you're
some kind of complete psychopath if you
don't believe they're actually coming
you can wait on your balcony for the guy
yeah if you have to track it non-stop in
real time because you're starving that
bad like a psychopath you can do that
both sites is giving you guys $100 of
free delivery credit for your first 7
days start your free deliveries download
the app and use the code Kay 80s 2020
that's right that's cats 2020 for $100
of free delivery credit for your first 7
days when you download the post mates
app support King in the sting anything
you need anytime you need it post made
it download post mates and save with
code cats 2020 it's postmates through
God's sakes hey look a lot of people
actually for everybody valentine's Day
is coming up yeah but you know what
you're not most people do like oh here's
a box of chocolate yeah here's some
flowers no that stuff lasts or here's
some flowers some times some girl gave
me flower dude she didn't know what she
was doing she wanted you to cook her
some cookies I don't know what she
wanted man yeah good thing that didn't
work out dude
but listen give the gift that keeps on
giving all year around by giving you the
the the time you see leave me alone I'm
doing this I am look I want you guys to
enjoy a stress-free Valentine's Day
you're stressing me out dude you're
stressing that shirt out with MVM tees
movement's best-selling styles already
packaged together and sleek gift boxes
they're sets that you guys are loved
whether it's for your man or for a woman
they have watch and jewelry combo boxes
upgrade to a deluxe box that has watch
bracelet and a pair of glasses
all-in-one one-and-done gift making made
easy dude you should get your therapist
a bracelet she would love that if you
need a little extra help choosing the
perfect stop for Valentine find exactly
what you need with movement 2020
valentine's day gift guide who says you
can't also gift yourself while you're at
it get yourself a dog collar get
yourself whatever MVM t special duo
boxes we trust best selling men's watch
may be old double over here bro dude
maybe we should get one box of you and I
share you got the wrists bro I'll take
the big thick one I do have small wrist
do but they're still growing up and
actually tennis wrist I've been soaking
them in milk at night you can get the
best-selling man's watch and women's
watch in once you can both look
wonderful get 15% off today with free
shipping and free returns by going to
MVM t.com / k 80s that man-made holiday
is gonna be fun man valentine's day
enjoy it take care of it Hey look it's a
great opportunity to get somebody you
care about something nice for them it's
an excuse it's not even about you enjoy
that free extra wat strap and free gift
box with every watch order go to MVM
t.com / k 80s for your most stress-free
Valentine ever ooh I hope all your
chocolates dude you are so dressed like
a kid who doesn't know how to dress and
that had you that's for a women that
played doubles tennis but you're both of
the women you like oh they call me dumb
double you know doubles a sad friend
feel come on bro you know mr. two-in-one
himself
Wow another day that's all
would do with it have some of this here
let me pour you a fresh glass of this oh
it almost fill it does want to admit he
doesn't have anything in the car
so he keeps doing this
we suck some of this what is this
can you waterboard me I need water not
by what else you got D we got our boy
Nick Vermeer oh boy Nick Nick Nick I
Boise where you from
buzz buzz the kind of submit a little
sink my end and they had a bar where you
have it walk up and are you can drink
tequila shots I drink a couple too many
of those and welcome next morning with
this wonderful Ponyboy tattoo he lost a
bet
Ponyboy he said he was getting drunk
with his boys tequila shots and then he
woke up with that Ponyboy
good been a lot worse my man could have
a dick on the other shoulder pretend
it's a lighthouse
Ponyboy is fun man Ponyboy it up bro
Ponyboy is BAE's I heard Nick no Ponyboy
Vaughn oh no it ain't dude you you've
never seen doubles and Ponyboy live
that's a new band
RAAA doubles and Ponyboy bro and we
throw double stuffed Oreos in the crowd
yeah that's gay magicians dude that
ain't no bang
okay no one's gonna see doubles and
Ponyboy the band that's gay magician
yeah you're right where is it Ponyboy
can you find it doubles you being sneaky
yes and where are the gay magicians at
dude I know I don't act like that I'll
straight but I'll tell you right now
Criss Angel you ain't fooling nobody
with all that goddamn makeup all the
[ __ ] time
and how many afflictions shirts did you
wear dude many as they got ya I got a
style bro I mean assless chap chin for
nobody he dated Britney Spears though
man nah
yeah sure he did he did man yeah he
tricked you into think he's datin but
dude how can you say all this
confidently
in that hat I'm talking to you with that
haircut dude I feel pretty confident
that ass looks like one of those has you
getting a gift bag you're like aw [ __ ]
they gave me this hat yeah I spy rocket
bro really no I'm joking man it looks
good man no it doesn't shot - Criss
Angel though dude you ain't fooling
nobody
you might fool my ponytail friend over
here Ponyboy friend you ain't fooling me
you tell me that's a straight man right
there okay okay you're right with them
Kris Jenner bangs yeah come on bro great
at magic though Bobby it up too rowdy
dollar I'll give him though yeah puts on
a hell of a show Mindfreak a man if he
sells it he sells that magic I saw him
one time how was it I don't remember how
to saw man is very good
do you wanna see him perform what I saw
him o at the store yeah David
Copperfield blow your mind he's good
then David Blaine is showing up David
Copperfield's 85 years old dude - movie
cuz you like Cadabra and you just end up
on an island butt-naked yeah did you
Ella bring girls out of the crowd but
just girls and fly them to an island
yeah I said Wow let's even make my dick
disappear yes swallow it like magic
[Laughter]
can't believe I'm even here today let's
keep this going what was this guy's
problem just got prom he sounds like
you're an alcoholic dude says he makes
some path life decisions when you drink
tequila yeah what else you gay you could
have woke up with a dying husband bro so
at least be on be happy that's all you
got yeah it was a little bit advertised
gonna woke up in Vietnam this one's a
little special this last one boys this
is Victor all right it's a board Victor
all right big Victor
[Music]
hi guys Victoria from Sweden Sweden this
is possibly sync by Inc what do you
think about face tattoos I guess my
first one when I was like 21 and it got
a lot worse hormone or what do you think
I also got this one both buzz buzz buzz
does that's full of good decisions I
look out yo dude yeah feel vaunteth you
[ __ ] yeah dude so many good decision bro
that's crazy man is that definitely if
you an angry meg Ryan is punched in the
face she's got a lot of work done so you
can't tell dude dude I feel better than
we get to meet this guy in Sweden I was
in Sweden I was in your country maybe he
came to show I feel bad if I don't get
to meet him though yeah uh move dude wow
man that's brave first of all you
definitely like up top you seem like
you've like you uh
like just got a gangbang bow a bunch of
squids really a lot of tats man it's
brave of you I can't hey that's that's
why I can go it's just it's just brave I
don't know what you do for work
once you start going on the face it
limits your options to make an income I
think it does for suffer and older for
our generation for like younger
generation bro I think they can do
whatever I don't think so you don't
think I think it'll be a president would
have faced that future future oh wow I
like your positivity but that ain't
happened but see that's a normal said if
you go with the Millennial mindset do
with the you know smoking somebody drugs
they don't [ __ ] that's right this
euphoria just [ __ ] each other anyways
this guy I like it it that's my thing
it's brave dude to get that's my boss'll
everyday it says I'm and then on his
eyebrows this says stage room true stay
true to your jaw I say this mount now
this gentleman has beautiful eyes I need
to have nice eyes in his head
good-looking dude man
and so tattoo your ear the blue color
looks good with the blue eyes you know
so he's at least fashionable I think I
could say his good taste got a tattoo a
view on his leg yeah it makes good so we
have a good taste let me make a smart
decision I'll hustle every day has
written on his forehead dude I like it
bro I like the I hustled a you do and
then family on the forehead hmm I said
some questions what do you do to work
are you a tattoo artist that would make
sense now that make sense if he works at
the Apple store that's like yeah are you
a huge fan of the movie venom and decide
to get all this work done you know and
trying to look like Marty I think it's
pretty cool man if you think back to
Native American they got a lot of things
tattooed on their body things written on
them anything that meant something you
know and it worked out for them it took
that early elbow why make you said hey
yeah you guys doing let's go wait
where's everybody going
that's a hey I told him with yep and now
you know they have casinos and stuff but
still you know it's just a fun job it's
not the same in imagine being if you're
Native American walking around and being
like oh man this used to be like my
great grandparents land and now it's and
then what about the preview out Ryan now
some ass
CVS on it ruin it really is kind of true
you know it's heartbreaking bro that's
life though isn't it well I mean that's
some of the old-school life where people
were just beating each other for land
like you can't do that any trying to
take over mmm trying to take over now
you can't go beat somebody for land you
know yeah but you cats we can do it like
oh yeah I need some Persians do they'll
beat you down for land bro that's what
I'm saying this coronavirus or whatever
if the Chinese built it this [ __ ] will
fall apart in three weeks bro
thank you God you'll never get it in
that hat nobody's coming near you but
also let's keep the walls up around
trying to do you look like pigs handler
bro that is a reference dude yeah little
creepy but there's still good references
yeah creepy the also knows what I'm
talking about yeah kid dude okay give to
kids yes Jesus man shoutout to this dude
for making good decisions though gang
[ __ ] bro you got eyes dude god bless
Sweden but I will see you as soon as
things get bad over here that virus hits
here I'm headed to Sweden dude bro the
only that virus is what you're gonna
catch dude billy-ray thyroid over here
dude
magician Africa dab a little more butter
on that bridge dance more gravy oh man
new pod - what did I say this all the
time there's not enough podcasts out
there there's not enough do I need more
yep my mom's doing a podcast now about
conversations she and I have yeah yeah I
mean my dad are you gonna do one on us
arguing oh really
yeah he's gonna break it down in case by
case aha apparent he's gonna fact-check
are you think fat check oh yeah you'll
test positive
here's what I want to say there's a new
podcast from wondering Network oh my god
I can't wait you're gonna call we
crashed we crashed do you know about me
you say wondering wonder yeah and we
crashed yeah from wondering yeah
just checking gosh man I'm just cross my
T's dot my your heart of thinking and
hard-of-hearing man yeah yeah here's
what I'm saying is no it's about the we
work building you know um like where
people like when I was in Europe turning
Europe all the buildings are we work
buildings you know we have them out here
too you have to brag about being in
Europe we works out here yeah my bad
dude when I was in uh also when I was in
Dayton Ohio
there's tons of we work bills but make
them come back to reality dude this is
the story this this podcast we crashed
is the story behind we work and how it
all and how it was headed up to be like
the next big thing like basically the
tests the Tesla of like um we're office
space yes they're like the Tesla of
office space thank you dude and then how
it all came crashing do you know I'm
foaming at the mouth we'll listen this
thing we crashed dude dude here it is
the host David Brown digs into what
happened tween we were its initial forty
seven billion dollar valuation to Adam
Newman being forced to pull the stocks
IPO resigns as CEO and watch the
shareholders value nosedive on just
forty days this dude here's the thing
Scott Galloway serves as a key advisor
on twenty nineteen out Newman had
fifteen thousand employees a private jet
and stood poised to become the world's
first trillionaire with we work or so he
thought not up in here Newman's vision
of we work was more than just man
renting office spaces he said it would
change the world
alright you're gonna hear about this
real f tarter now he really dropped at
all conflicts of interest mismanagement
and losses soon had investors doubting
the success despite a desperate desire
to crown the next tech unicorn dude
here's the thing around the water cooler
people are inhaling it the largest
destruction shareholder value since
Enron Wow that doesn't get your ears
around a racial slur isn't a running
back for the death count that might be
Donnie Enron don't miss don't miss the
January 29th premiere of wonder he's we
crashed on Apple podcasts alright boy
will debate club
but first what does it show even a
that's what are you doing dude you
freaking little hidden boy over there
popstar to thank you now young women to
be in 57 years old I didn't want to have
a seat alright right Chris Hanson you
know fool nobody chin right they out
that 21 year old your [ __ ] hates 53
nice try bro and then get her to [ __ ]
guzzle a bunch of sake and charging a
heart card yes son Chris hands son Chris
handsome no it is getting racist what
are you guys up to Derek
I haven't heard anything out of you guys
today I'm out chillin man just been
smoking weed yeah Chuck I like to watch
the show the best way possible cat how
are you adjusting a single life so far
so good you know keeping my feet hidden
waiting for the one or people asking yes
you're waiting and just waiting for the
one you're just sweet to a serial dater
or are you a bunch of dates just broke
up Brendan yeah I mean I really don't
know I've been with the same dude since
I was like 14 goddess this is all very
[ __ ] cat gone wild Wow Wow boo boo
baby but a do baby baby let's go to the
pound
dang you don't know what to do if your
house assist is he doing all right yeah
he's doing good check up on him every
now and then yeah top man go with the
breakups is tough right
what come with your breakups is tough
you know yeah but everybody has to do
them you know that's really getting
shots just do it bro you got to have
your heart broke every now and then do
you ever bet you ever walk into a room
and you can't find the lights you know
yeah that's Brendan what he's found
sentence on the wall what do you or chew
it Justin laughing and then finding the
light and then punching it punch it
why just keep finding stuff been ruined
I don't know he just don't know what to
do Britain also got a bunch of money
Britt never set it on fire
Britain refer to a filing cabinet once
has a warm strange refrigerator yeah you
refer to your service as your best
friend Shawn everybody feel Brennan
what's up Shawn I'm up here in the
Northwest Territories build nice roads
it's minus 58 degrees Fahrenheit it's
converted for you I got a little debate
club for you hockey fights or baseball
fights gang rape but fudge best friends
are [ __ ] penguin hockey fights are
baseball fights this what's always
interesting how racists are fighting
sports because if it happens then be a
people freak out everybody gets a spit
ball like the n-c-double-a candidate
that guy suspended for the year Rygaard
white guy [ __ ] punches another white
guy in hockey was like yeah yeah I think
hockey mean a lot of really toned down
the hockey fights it used to be more
fighting and now they don't have as many
fights I think a lot of people are upset
about that but if I had to pick one of
the other man I liked baseball the
baddest out there too
yeah and that's what I don't understand
people always throw the bat off and
there's rules to baseball
you can't even charge them out with a
bat do you ruin your on that do charge
nolan ryan nowhere i just that old man
standing
those are the old days where somebody
got you in a headlock you stayed in it
like it was like you know what to do
yeah you then had a responsibility oh I
have to stay in the headlight remember
when that white guy charged Sammy Sosa
mail icon that tousled and all the cream
came off is he's super slippery you know
and then all the white dude ended up on
Sammy Sosa's face he know he had skin
opens up a bleach like this well yeah I
just got an email Sam he says he's gonna
hatch sometime later this year he's
gonna fly off into the distance
I like hockey fights I expect them it's
kind of cool to see two grown men on ice
fight each other
yeah and it's something beautiful while
seeing men fight on skates yes but I
also like when they grab each other's
shirts and pull mother has old school
bully style yeah um but baseball for
sure baseball you'll see a lot of it we
do this what's great about baseball
everybody jumps in yeah dude yeah
anything can happen you can get out
there and sneak somebody how do you feel
he was like hey I was trying to take a
very not like baseball fights yeah I
would love to see some somebody uh throw
something in somebody's eyes or
something glitter somebody's face and
then punch them because then the guy you
have to see him after and the interview
has glitter all over his face
that do glitter is such a you know under
you substance I think hockey's also
weird too because when those two white
dudes fight well it's one dudes job
that's all he does you can't he don't
have any skills
yeah only skills kind of skating drill
it's just like a Hells Angel eyes
yeah like true lambier he's just out
there just beating people remember
basketball used to have Bill Laimbeer
just a guy who's just supposed to punch
when it came here the relay to Jordan
got lots of fights dude yeah hold it BA
it was really good only it was good it
was all better when you can fight a
little bit more man they would let it
let it out on the court you know now
it's like it's all I don't know what's
going on bro it's definitely gotten
different it's got what does the fancy
fancy 79 percent hockey mm-hmm people
love those Hockey Fights men but just
standing there and they just keep
punching each other you know someone
gets [ __ ] up this is my thing when's
the when's the ref know when to break it
up I never do that one like a once over
because you see the refs kind of jump in
sometimes didn't you see one bad [ __ ]
bruiser be knocking [ __ ] out with one
shot yeah dude I think you have to have
a level of that go on cuz there needs to
be a level of like relieving the tension
of like I said you know like it's part
of the game it's part of the courses I
had a get in for certain when I was in
Denver out of avalanche play I forget
his name because our main enforcer and
he came to the gym and asked me to teach
him proper techniques for punching and
toggling the OSI I think I'm her father
nice before look I'll be honest at the F
fuggin of uh fed myself two packs of ham
with the frigerator door still open I've
been icing on the fight yeah he's like
Oh for practice we're gonna drink these
real cold smoothies in the retreat I got
a brain freeze [ __ ] I felt like
I really let him down oh so you don't
have any techniques no oh you can't wear
a scarf are they warm up Nick this is a
Dominic from Michigan
[Laughter]
yeah [ __ ] man homeboy Dom Dom from Grand
Rapids right there Tommy
what's up boys now I'm gonna got a
Michigan here
got any big clubs happen for you so what
was three coming up it's better way to
dodge the draft enrollment in college or
failing a drug test need to know clock's
ticking Gang Gang buzz buzz gang brother
just gotta say he'd be an actor in like
a movie like yeah like a wild western
movie or lay the gun correct Adrian
produce or like a Talon job [ __ ] 17
or something he's gonna rob a bank
yeah I could see him robbing a bank on a
horse around like a big goat yeah there
was always that kid dude like I never
over sometimes we have horses worried
huh there's always that kid that would
show up on a goat in it was a horsey
bike yes Oh God
why'd you go to pogs ah ha ha ha what is
your horse have Oh watch your horse just
eatin garbage well the rest of our
horses are galloping heap like yeah and
he would make the horses sounds up the
side of his mouth
[Laughter]
don't you be quiet yeah meanwhile his
horses just finishing off of a milk
carton his horse is just polishing huh
[Laughter]
man we always had this boy named Roy and
he was thick - dude he was homosexual
zero had early onset homosexuality oh
yeah oh my god holy sugar in his tank
dude and then at some points no tank
just a whole bunch of sugar
hey don't shut up on ya and he always
wanted us to play all these back he let
us play these battleship games they had
a big bathtub in there usually they want
to build like forts and you hide in this
floor no this deal was all about the
high seas man use one of his navel gaze
you know original sea monkeys are the
same one of them old-school water gaze
brush Jeezy's brush out the Atlantis
gaze gang bra what else we doing good
yeah answer the question oh good Kirk I
think was that one of the answers what's
the better way to get to dodge the draft
enroll in college or fail a drug test
I think you'd get in with failed drug
tests these days let's take anybody drug
cuss can get you into can't get you out
of the military I don't think usually
get you into the military
he's like yeah we'll take you do you
hold a gun uh I would probably shoot
take off one of my thumbs or something
yeah I probably stab myself in the eye
or some [ __ ] just cut your song keep
your eyes well you're still going with a
thumb bro but you don't wanna be that
one-eyed guy in the lunch line you gotta
say so in a way you can relate to it are
you right Doug uh they're not gonna take
us cuz we're too old no we're not for
the draft we are there I'm not yeah you
are
you are a fight boy can you imagine
Brendon over there with his tight-ass
little helmet his grenades going off
because they can't even stay on his belt
anymore how about you were there like
dudes I guess I'm [ __ ] why is getting
those two canteens of water behind like
that like a loser's ass cheeks yeah
Jesse's cheeks yeah why yeah yeah
damn that [ __ ] their names hanging
out the back those are his cheats but I
kept bringing liquorice to a gunfight
why does that guy keep acid we have
dunkaroo hey shut the [ __ ] about dude
like I said nine MREs and we're only on
the bus to basic this guy is not taking
pictures of the shoes going prewar kick
[Laughter]
and this friend who's always sad with
the mullet keeps Tom about old story
from his home Wow Brittany's gonna be so
shocked when he can't load bullets into
his black rifle coffee oh it's okay I'm
already armed no your caffeine a no
weapons get me out here uh what I want
to tell you man is I think you should be
in a Western dude if you had to choose
one a bleep 72% failed drug tests I take
a digit often at least you'd have a good
story about your like Oh wallet if
you're you know your thumb like Oh cuz I
don't want to be in the war but is it
still Don't Ask Don't Tell cuz you just
say you're gay oh yeah I said oh I think
they let it be you got you can be gay
anyway try yeah oh yeah I'll still get
you in the gang gay they're gonna love
you in here
[Laughter]
yeah you wanna give me one of the Jeeps
you're an MRAP dude y'all gonna ride on
your back can you swim your submarine of
his own where is everybody
you got oh good boy this is a boar loin
Lawrence from Manchester and he Larry
want some Manchester so feel so Brendan
it's a brother
laureen's for Manchester UK here run
here what's the bad film The Green Mile
or Shawshank Redemption I'm pretty sure
Stephen King wrote both of those you've
never been pretty sure of something I
want to [ __ ] call that into question
pretty sure correct did he really
elementary books nothing better than
shopping and that's over John Coffey
yeah I didn't like the way they treated
John Coffey this circus models he's a
circus mouth it's so good dude dream out
that [ __ ] so sad it's good it's long no
it's super long he throws up those weird
like yeah that's what I got to spend
like the devil
yeah and buy that [ __ ] oh yeah he drew
up that Lord it was like throwing up the
positive energy into somebody gonna be
suck the cancer out that dudes wife
threw it up onto another dude that was
good man but nothing's gonna take
Shawshank I think you got to stay sha
Shan Shan say you know that ending they
said overtaking my antic don't ya the
gala did the approval ain't nothing I
saw shall Saints on I watch dude yep
nothing's on our watch what's up Doug
AMC movies baby
hey calm down boy
we're going with a fancy affair 69% with
the shank bro you got to yeah the fact
that 40 peoples percent were a green
mile and you watch Green Mile again it's
so good it's cool it is happy
everybody's giving a high as [ __ ] all
day he told me that Legoland was real
sad he told me in the area he told me
said do you know it's a [ __ ] riot
that Schindler's List he is like man boy
in the Striped Pyjamas I can't wait til
they come out with a sequel she was
priceless man all right guys let's wrap
it up interstate and then we'll be done
up first this is Christian it's our girl
Christian got a little deal going on
she's due for a haircut what she's about
due for I'm telling you right now look
at this mullet damn King it or sting it
boys come on baby might be mullets baby
mutt I think King a man a baby cuz they
don't know what's going on you might as
well let him have a little bit of flair
out the back now you don't want anything
that a dog could grab onto you don't
want to have too much back their word
dog you don't want to braid it back down
that's some adult could grab on to but
also that's the that's the Lord let the
Lord is your stylist and then once your
kid to have that mullet yeah with your
accent I'm sure other people dig it down
in fact if you cut that baby's hair some
problem yeah I need you let that Ricky
Bobby flow you feel me yeah dude if you
cut that baby's hair you're not gonna be
on a city council so I think you gotta
let that [ __ ] let that look i King know
to let that top rock baby let that top
rock rock dog
up next this is William was a better on
the Breton Theo
interesting at doing your own yard work
Gang Gang buzz-buzz Gang Gang William
sweatshirts dirty as [ __ ] he's doing
hard work you want him to be in a damn
ball gown well he hasn't started though
that's what there's dog here on insect
boys asked should we do it himself or
not dude if we say no
this guy never do is you hard every day
right
you're the artwork guy man I always see
with the I love it man the ficuses I
think he's lazy man if you're a grown
man you're a dad you gotta put in that
lonnie time dude no one appreciates a
nice lawn than doing it yourself yeah I
wash my cars myself I do my lawn myself
a methane get out there with these hoes
man oh yeah my dad dude
yeah why are these hoes down yeah I like
to wash my own car man I do like that
and if I had a yard I would probably go
out there and do something it's relaxing
is it praise God
well yeah so yeah well you must say you
take care of your yard man first of all
I can tell you right now your neighbors
are pissed bro
okay do you have a look I give it a
couple of years worth of leaves and we
say you're doing your own yard work oh
you had a park that's a park that you
know if you live in an apartment here's
lying to us oh yeah this is some random
park and showing us all these leaves
dude that would take months is that a
Shetland pony as well in that leaf pile
right you know what's happening man
yeah it looks like he's just had a
[ __ ] your local park man what about
tiny Tommy got ever seen the world's
smallest Pony mm-hmm
Tom Thumb is his name I don't like
ponies man hey can we bring up a picture
of Tom Thumb world smallest Pony Chris
angel you guys don't know [ __ ] tiny Tom
you remember rob dyrdek bought a pony so
the thing's a beast man really
yes it is like exhausting get some
images of that animal there's like a
[ __ ] pony
praise God no that's world smallest
right there Tom Thumb I met him well was
he nice
yeah it was a let's like you'd be a
little [ __ ] don't like it because he
gets right a lot of attention you know
I'm saying oh he definitely I think he
had kind of an air about him it was
after lunch when I met him
oh okay so was it hungry yeah he's like
in a good mood but anyway beautiful
animal he's still alive I'm sure he is
I'm sure he is I don't believe this is
this guy's long but I definitely should
I believe in doing your own lawn work
dude yeah especially if you have a
riding mower man okay some of the new
riding mowers man you put a riding mower
on top of a Roomba and you can just fall
asleep you're good man take care y'all
y'all what's the fan say Do It Yourself
hey why it wouldn't know what y'all said
it's Kings Canyon all day yeah I say
king of man get out there and do it do
your [ __ ] get that ass Rob we get the
neighbors dude take your shirt off hey I
get that tag get a smoke going and then
burn that Poly's with your own cigarette
little bit of gasoline and then cook a
frank on it while it's burning yeah let
the neighbors know what the [ __ ] up
dude dude I like Franks that have been
cooked on gas gasoline only fueled fires
brother don't know this charcoal [ __ ] I
like to taste a Pontiac in the pack into
my Frank a little Trans Am [ __ ] dog
like a dog sweaty too man swag and get a
little bit a little little little crispy
and then burst a little bit go down the
tosod a little sauerkraut little mustard
dude I [ __ ] deep throat that whole
thing I thought you were trying to get
the guy out of the military okay you're
trying to get him back homey or at least
the Navy dude that's definitely you'll
get drafted directly into the Navy if
you make that that video my last one is
Conor
how's our boy Connor hey oh hey Brandon
could be Ari Shaffir Anderson Oklahoma
just looking
Tolson one of y'all's King or sting it
on hunting have you done it would you do
it you know what are your viewpoints on
it
I know Theo used to find chimpanzees for
fun so I feel like he's probably has a
pretty good take on it
Halle one nice dangling big nuts Davis
big nice back bronze whispering hidden
wants kill them scare them animals away
dude that guy but I also think your
giant bright orange hat might give you
away as well well that's good even on
other hunters to shoot you do you hunt
in the wrong parts then bro you think
you had a ghost hunting at a spa okay
dude I say God here's what I say get out
there with the weapon get a knife get
two knife get a fork and a knife and go
sneak up on that animal the
old-fashioned way a bow hunting I dig it
man but I think sometimes the rifle
stuff the bullet tree too far off maybe
too you know I'm saying to you two
counties over and you killing a [ __ ]
iguana or something that thing never
even knew you existed you know when
you're hunting the [ __ ] Panthers with
a drone I got worse than a Theo on
hunting or thing he's hunted with dude
downtown I like I also like bow hunting
I get down with hunt it's just not for
me man cuz I'll be the guy when you
shoot that I am I'm crying I think
there's a cutest [ __ ] I don't want to
got this thing like [ __ ] Jeffrey
Dahmer then carry it back [ __ ] all
these miles I'm down for the hike and
all that but when you shoot that thing
I'll turn my back dude yeah I like I
think if you shoot it but you got to go
up there and be with it while it does
that's my thing you need to talk to him
like Avatar and it was whisper in his
ear go sama come on yeah yeah remember
that yeah I think if there's a little
bit more of a bedside what's I called
your bedside manner you got a good
bedside manner with these animals you
know like my boy heat-seeking [ __ ]
missiles and [ __ ] up reindeer yeah you
can't be killing something Missouri from
Denver you know like some of that stuff
is just too much so I think if you got
that silverware style where you sneak up
with a sharp knife or you sneak up with
a sword not sure you [ __ ] take it to
a raccoon I get it and all and look as
many records as you want to kill [ __ ]
bro
without their raising hell bro I like
raccoons do they look like
burglars their hands are cool yeah I
like going to hell maybe yeah
well yeah IIIi like hunting in scope you
wanna hunt man and eat your own [ __ ]
that's cool I just don't want to see it
I don't like getting out there and being
all hungry either
no I'll piggyback with you and I forget
we're hunting and I try to be and then
I'll be loud you know oh yeah yeah I saw
suddenly I'll just watch an episode of
king of the hill on my phone without a
headphone people like wouldn't and I
keep asking where's the snacks at me
just started do yummy snacks
we just started yeah we gotta kill what
we I know but I see nothing why don't
you kill all pack of gushers into my
hand there I'm sorry we hundreds of
nakedness Briggs I'm [ __ ] starving
yeah where's your clothes huh I'm scared
I'm fine
[Laughter]
that's a big fellas boys that's it doggy
dog awesome man I'll see you guys coming
up soon somewhere at the end of the
month I'll be in a Toronto at the end of
February I'll be in Toronto
I'm Ponyboy I'll be in Red Bank I'll be
in Oroville casino for February 15th
come out therefore thanks for
Valentine's Day Thanksgiving bro in San
Antonio this week Thursday Friday 7:00
Tony Oh and then for Valentine's Day
weekend I'm in Ontario California Bay
Bay so bring your loved ones and let's
figure it out man amen
all right race my case returns next week
from fan submitted videos and
relationship advice we had some but we
need some more it's classy and we're
pretty close on a new merch launch so
we'll keep you guys posted and thank you
guys for supporting the podcast love you
guys because